all right it is time to lace up the
cleats soccer returns to cashman field
tomorrow
as the las vegas lights kick off their
home opener and we have lights owner and
ceo
brett lashbrook joining us live this
morning with it looks like
cash the soccer rocker hey brett good
morning
good morning viva lights from cashman
field here in downtown las vegas
get your soccer fever on brett you are
so much fun i've been telling john how
much i've wanted to talk to you because
you are so
exciting okay so want to talk about
tomorrow night uh
tell us what's going on and how excited
are you to kick off the season
here at home it has the lights are back
on we see the lights at the end of the
tunnel
tomorrow night is our home opener ten
dollar tickets adults
five dollars for kids five straight
weekends of home games
come on down any age any background if
you're looking for a
saturday night soccer fiesta cashman
field catch the soccer rocker the
coolest mascot in sports will be here
too
we can't wait to see it hey brett you
guys always have such fun promotions
and there's a new field side option this
season tell us about that
so we have two field site options one we
kept hearing about the aviators and
their brand new swanky pool out in the
outfield
we wanted to do better so we got 10
pitch side swimming pools little baby
pools but they're swimming pools right
next best seats in the house
bring your kids sit in the water the
coolest seats in sports and then
with our partnership with findlay toyota
and john barr who will do anything to
sell you a car
if you drive a toyota to the game you
register with us first
we're gonna let you sit in the most
covent compliant seats in the history of
professional sports you're gonna drive
your toyota car
and sit next to the bench you can sit in
your car if you want but mask off you
can sit on top of your car
have fun viva lights that's what we do
here in downtown las vegas
that sounds amazing so brett you're
going to have pool are they like kiddie
pools
or what kind of pools they're little
kiddie pools but you know let's be let's
be respectful here they are still pools
we have ten baseball has one just
remember
okay that sounds great uh you know
it has been a year more than a year now
for frontline workers it's been so hard
and you guys are doing something really
special for them
yeah we've partnered with the castro de
castro verde law firm
and as part of their partnership they
wanted to do something really big and
they came up with the idea as part
of their partnership with us is that
they are going to donate
2 000 tickets for every home game in
june to anyone who is a frontline worker
and you know at first we were talking
about what is a frontline worker how do
you define it
and credit to the cash diverter they
said it's defined however anyone defines
it if you believe you are a front-line
worker
come to lightsfc.com backslinefrontline
and there's up to 2000 free tickets
any game this month all four weekends so
we really want to thank you right we're
calling it vegas is back
and it's been a really difficult year
for all of us and this is kind of a time
for us to again no pun intended
turn the lights back on and we want to
thank those front line workers
absolutely you can get in the kiddie
pool hop on your truck
and watch some good soccer we can't wait
brett it's going to be so fun
home opener tomorrow night viva lights
viva lights
at cashman thank you so much for joining
us hope you guys are doing really well
it's great to see you
thank you okay have a good morning
honestly
needs to be part of our morning show
every day most energetic human i love it
all right don't forget we are giving
away tickets too to the lights all this
week here on channel eight
you've got one more chance to win a
family four pack of tickets today
just watch for your cue to call this is
our 4 pm newscast so
that's with kirsten and christian later
on today we need